oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade because I'm in
Cincinnati and I am unable to record it
home so I decided to drop on in and
we're gonna play a game before we do
that say my way by the way highway baby
keep looking over here instead over here
I know anyway how's it going everybody
are you doing okay how are you doing
Oh God closer wait
hi hey guys anyway as you guys can tell
my hair is not up to par so we were
gonna style my hair and I was gonna have
way do it but we don't actually have any
gel we look through his whole house so
we decided that we're gonna use this
sunscreen bottle but this game actually
requires us to use a keyboard so you
guys don't even know game we're playing
before we got to do this so let's get to
it go you know how I like it so much
that's not nearly oh yeah oh yeah just
screw the bottle right into my hair do I
do this one now you do it Oh
all right so now that that's done my
hair looks great guys and we're gonna
play game and I know a lot of you wants
everyone at home has asked themselves
this one question what could be better
than one Hitler if every one you left
yet it's still bigger please probably
all right wait hey let's go back welcome
back to the game where we play as to
Hitler's double Hitler double Hitler oh
yes let's play you will be on the
keyboard and I will be on the mouse with
you both yes no no didn't you even pay
attention now the game was good oh you
were looking at it for like ten years
okay okay your AMD all right oh god
that's gonna pick up on the mic isn't it
yes probably uh okay turn it down no no
we need to turn the tv down no no no
okay this one burning down all the way
down you don't need you all right okay
but you guys can still but you guys
never mind what you guys can still hear
anyway so what's gonna happen is I
better be controlling leaning left and
right with the mouse and you're gonna be
stepping and then you need to control
the space to start and stop painting
when we go there because as you know
Hitler started out his career in art
school well let me read this the
brothers legally grew butter to Austrian
news united in their passion for art but
nowhere to unleash a fervor
until one day they decided upon a
cunning plan stacked on top of each
other they would enroll in the most
prestigious art school in the in under a
false pretence of being aware of no
other peril that spring from their ruse
in the future okey dokey let's go oh
there's more than one
are you just holding down left you know
this is supposed to be gentle okay yes
you're right there please come in okay
we just got a trace so it's bass okay no
don't know working friends again
but I'm not moving oh oh you're so thank
you thank you take another step uh-huh
oh that's so good and I'm just gonna
fill in such a beautiful circle thank
you we're trying to get into art school
because as you have you brushed up on
your Hitler biography I think I'm pretty
sure I got that okay so yeah okay all
right wait I wasn't ready he's okay yeah
wait uh-huh looks good
whoa oh we didn't do it why am I in
charge of the drawing
Joseph years old but oh no everyone
knows okay you need to step there okay
that did not work okay okay good no good
yep I'm gonna go back another once he
get there oh okay I see what you got
yeah
stop calling me I do not have time is
okay more step one more step good good
good good okay good
no no no no no I didn't say step yeah
who's calling me I dunno I always go for
the nipple first you know maybe you're
in trail would be a good Han I'll get
that and just the articulate to the face
here going on and then we're gonna go
here okay now trace the arc good more
step I'm a lean finish out the other arm
comes logical conclusion all right let
keep step as you can see what your
detail that's a good toes yeah use my
articulate skills to get the okay now I
go to the crime and now we got a graphic
that was completely I've been given
their best Eagle cobblers stills are
their dreams crushed Bay the reader is
admission brownie and yet there's beer
stood unwavering is the world of the
Dalton Sparta oh it's calling me
no mom my mom is calling me my mama
misses me in Cincinnati unwavering his
new world of adults and sparks a new
fascination in them they needed their
mission to become low on the adult
all right we're like the one ring oh no
no no a scent of evil oh dear in fear be
sure to read the crowd and dress them
directly okay
watch their body language and turn to
face him you got right move your upper
body I can't you can't step oh it's all
me now yes do you know anything about
German history Oh mystery of Hitler and
how Hitler became Hitler yes yes we
failed art school or we pastor we did a
great job art school yes we've been we
went and did the wave yes we did and
then he did the wave there are any sound
bites take it from us cool yeah whoo
just gonna be a mishmash of things most
offensive game where they got ever
played well yeah you know it's just
going to be all about love and happiness
and acceptance and now Hitler was
actually just oh so young he looked like
a little boy there well really really
you don't think so really are you being
a kiss help you're being serious okay
the country is theirs but the shukaku
rulers bigger and ain't unsatisfied
through fur hand out in all directions
to subjugate the peoples of the earth
and enslave them to the toddlers wheel
oh we get to direct the war all right
we're gonna step this way of course all
right we need to get the are we blue or
orange we the enemy is red we are all
right powerful blue so we've to send our
Panthers into the race the Panzerfaust
was very strong in aiding Koga yes I'm
ready we got our troops here okay so
what we're gonna do is we're going to
walk up here jiggling me okay I did you
I'll tell you okay step to the right
step step step step one more I'm just
keeping you at arm's length I don't try
very much
my general friend okay that's up to the
right good
okay no no no move no move all right
don't move don't we know the horace
ladder do not move don't move wait what
we're just giving them only freakin the
bone front right what do we do go can
you do this step to the left in what in
this scenario do we need drastic move
any moment go lean back a bit good ease
up on it okay okay good a little baby
step all right little baby steps good
baby steps okay one more oh yeah yeah
this is so good whoa there buddy little
baby step this way okay all right so all
right whenever you're ready all right
now my fuher phone interview already oh
okay okay so we're gonna go through the
northern passage here okay wait step
over to that guy over there to lead the
troops but they're going out of their
way to kill their enemies Harry Potter
you love your songs your horse Harry
nor the two voices coming from rock that
is a little drunk down below we really
is a little bit
Oh fine another step gentlemen I like to
really know what I'm getting into
come over this way just gonna just stick
you laid up this way just need a step to
the right oh why did I choose this path
I don't know okay like a surgeon haha
just take step to the right my friend
northern wider yes more robust I like
that
okay this is very uncomfortable is where
we were before okay left or right I mean
take one step to the right this seems
like it's gonna stay steady he's another
one just tiny gentle got it do not go
down
our misfortune the cichlid groovers give
their all what a bleep failed again and
so the Nazarene given up on their
adventure ended apps for epilogue oh no
no I would not thank you very much okay
so thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this video
sorry if we over blew the mic many many
times throughout the whole time the
whole time basically we were screaming
right into mikrobitti the way hope you
guys enjoyed this if you did check out
Wade's channels in the description Lord
million seven thousand seven you
probably already know about but check it
out anyway and thank you again everybody
for watching and as always we will
I